hi mr. Han doesn't let anybody ancestry
brought me here today to do a job of one
of my ancestors I don't know the
ancestor and I don't know the job we're
very close-knit family there are a lot
of us we try to talk to each other at
least a half a dozen times a day very
Jewish my paternal grandparents are from
Ukraine patriarch of that family
embarked from liver to first cousins
grew up in Northern California I have
the room is asleep this is so cool so
all these people are dead right yeah yes
thanks for bringing that up dad is still
living thank God
yeah Lawrence that's my father my father
ah there's our wedding announcement Oh
cute you guys okay grandpa my dad was a
banker should I go to Abraham my
great-grandfather
where it is 1910 census
okay what's the occupation what does
that say Taylor Lera you told me your
grandfather was a textile magnate let's
try to build up the image before you
agree to marry me did you notice the
native language yes
Yiddish was the language our parents
spoke so we kids didn't know what they
were talking about I think some of these
shops were probably all Jewish and my
guess is they just spoke Yiddish so
there's a section I just noticed it says
can read there they were all literate
all that does is it facilitates their
entry into the workforce we assume they
all came from an agricultural background
and within a few years they all learned
skills i watch a show where they make
clothes are we gonna be making clothes
we are oh I'm so excited
[Music]
thanks Eliza Molly today we found out
that my great grandfather was a tailor
and I want to learn how to make a jacket
for my dad I don't know how to sew I
don't have to cut patterns
mr. Hong could show you how things were
done back in the day because it is all
done pretty much the same way now how
long has mr. Han been doing this oh you
boy tailoring or man this is the 40
dudes Wow it's in your blood
oh yeah well I think it's week one with
the basic maybe laser something to
improve on my store-bought oh maybe just
a little bit in terms of fit let's get
you metric oh I watch on the shoulder
like this 18 is when I see I think mr.
Han can do the weighs great-grandfather
is rolling Harry you have to be exact
lasses mr. Han is gonna show you how to
cut and pattern this jacket Oh God
okay
oh look at my suit yeah this is freaking
that's a pocket this is how they've done
it for hundreds of years and he's the
only one who cuts can you trust me okay
kids it's the happiness this is the real
deal I'm actually cutting fabric wow
this is a little blue yeah well you're a
professional and I mean you can have a
talent it's like in my blood I'm in the
work space where I'm gonna be putting
together the suit and it's very similar
to how I would imagine my great
grandfather must have done his tailoring
no it's all in pieces I can't do it it's
a faster way to do this is really really
dense there's got to be there's no
guided way why don't we do this way
sorry great-grandfather but this way is
more fun I'm where it's so fun I'm bad
you guys are so good at tailoring
[Music]
here's the jacket that I made all by
myself it's beautiful
just getting heat from mr. Han middle a
great grandfather would be proud I just
want to thank ancestry for this
opportunity I got to make a connection
to my great grandfather I think that
it's really incredible that you have the
same career for 50 years he was
dedicated to this profession and it's
similar to mr. Hein so many things in
this world have changed this just hasn't
changed my tailoring days are done this
was my one and only piece it's a
one-of-a-kind
[Music]